good morning Hank it's Tuesday so today
I want to discuss what we know about the
relationship between Donald Trump's
presidential campaign and the Russian
government's interference in our 2016
elections but first a couple notes
Russia is a huge and massively diverse
country of 144 million people but in the
context of this election meddling we are
talking specifically about Vladimir
Putin and his government Russia and the
US are currently adversaries Putin's
regime has sought to undermine democracy
and democratic institutions around the
world and in the u.s. is view invaded a
sovereign nation but whether the United
States and Russia are friends is not
actually that relevant to the legal
questions at hand also there is a lot of
speculation about this story online for
the purposes of this video I'm only
going to refer to events that have
either been confirmed by the people who
participated in them or reported
independently by two separate news
organizations sources as always in the
video info below okay here we go
the Department of Homeland Security in
the Office of the Director of National
Intelligence have stated with high
confidence that the Russian government
sought to influence the outcome of the
u.s. presidential election favoring
Donald Trump over Hillary Clinton
they've also stated that Russia's leader
Vladimir Putin personally oversaw this
operation which actually shouldn't come
as that much of a surprise the Putin
regime has a history of trying to sway
foreign elections and also Trump's
policy positions were broadly much more
favorable to Putin than Clinton's policy
positions I mean as far back as 2007
Trump said that Putin was doing a great
job
the Trump campaign even cooked proposed
language from the official Republican
party platform about supporting Ukraine
in their ongoing conflict with Russia
okay so the Putin regime meddled in our
election in at least three ways by a
disinformation campaign in which they
created and shared inaccurate news
stories by trying to breach election
data in several states and by hacking
the Democratic National Committee and
DNC leader John Podesta to access their
emails which they then released to
WikiLeaks now you may not believe all of
that and certainly both WikiLeaks and
the Russian government deny it but there
is overwhelming agreement not just
within US intelligence circles but also
among both Republican and Democratic
members of Congress who as you may have
noticed struggle to find common ground
on pretty much anything the email hack
in particular made a significant impact
because it created a huge imbalance of
information the public had access to all
these Democratic emails many of which
one might charitably described as sleazy
but not to any similar Republican emails
might have existed it's a bit like
saying can you believe all this crap and
candidate X's tax returns when candidate
Y doesn't release their tax returns at
all now you can say and you ought to
that political parties just shouldn't be
sleazy but my point is only that it
created an information imbalance and
that by choosing whose emails we saw
Putin had a lot of say in the election
narrative of course none of that means
the election was illegitimate it wasn't
or that Trump didn't win he did and
benefiting from a foreign government's
propaganda initiative is not a crime
however colluding with that government
is probably the u.s. election law says
that a foreign national be they Canadian
or Russian or Martian cannot make a
contribution or a donation of anything
of value in connection with a US
election it also says that no American
can solicit or knowingly accept a
donation or anything of value from a
foreign national I suspect we're gonna
hear the phrase thing of value a lot in
the coming months by the way in part
because the courts haven't been super
clear at deciding what it means if
hypothetically you receive damning
information about your opponent from a
foreign national and then share that
information that is probably receiving a
thing of value but it hasn't been
entirely established and there are a lot
of nuances here have you received a
thing of value if you know about the
thing and to prove of sharing it but
don't share it yourself did you solicit
a thing of value if you set up a meeting
with a foreign national in the hopes
that would provide something they didn't
provide etc so many people in Trump's
campaign had past relationships with
Putin's regime Trump's one-time campaign
manager Paul Manafort received around 30
million dollars working for Oleg
Deripaska who was seen as one of putin's
closest business confidants Michael
Caputo and early Trump advisor had
previously worked on a Russian campaign
to improve Putin's image among Americans
Trump's Attorney General Jeff Sessions
had to recuse himself from the Russia
investigation after it was revealed he'd
had previously undisclosed meetings with
Sergey Kiss lyac Russia's ambassador to
the United States and Michael Flynn
Trump's first national security adviser
failed to disclose payments that were
made to him by an arm of the Russian
government and failure to disclose such
payments is illegal for former military
officers Flynn also talked several times
to Sergey kis lyac during the transition
the period after the election but before
Trump became president one of those
calls occurred on December 29th which
happened to be the same day the u.s.
announced new sanctions on Russia
flynn initially denied that he discussed
sanctions on that call but it became
apparent that there was evidence to the
contrary because kiss leox calls are
routinely monitored by US intelligence
discussing sanctions policy on that call
was possibly illegal I mean Flynn was
not yet the national security adviser
but he was trying to negotiate foreign
policy but a greater concern is that the
day after Trump learned that Flynn had
lied about discussing sanctions Trump
asked FBI director James Comey for
loyalty and then the day after Flynn
eventually resigned Trump asked Comey to
drop the Flint investigation altogether
this is alarming because in the United
States the Justice Department and the
FBI are supposed to operate
independently from the White House
that's part of the reason FBI directors
serve a 10-year term they're supposed to
be above party politics and not beholden
to one particular leader Trump asking
Comey to drop the Flynn investigation
was a significant breach of protocol in
fact some have argued that it amounts to
obstruction of justice which is the
charge that Richard Nixon was eventually
impeached for and then a few months
later Trump fired James Comey initially
the White House said the FBI director
was being fired for his mishandling of
the Hillary Clinton email case but then
after a few days of trying on various
justifications Trump acknowledged that
it was mostly about the collusion with
Russia investigation but if firing Comey
was intended to make the investigation
and that gambit definitely failed
because a few days later the Department
of Justice appointed a special counsel
Robert Muller he is tasked with building
a team to look into collusion and any
matters that arise from the
investigation since then mowers been
doing just that and it's been reported
that he's working with at least two
grand juries to decide who if anyone
should be charged with crimes the most
serious evidence of collusion that has
emerged so far involves a meeting with a
Kremlin connected Russian lawyer that
was attended by Donald Trump jr. Paul
Manafort and Jared Kushner the
president's son-in-law and senior
advisor so during the set up for the
meeting Donald Trump jr. was told via
email that the lawyer had quote
incriminating information about Hillary
Clinton that she wanted to share as
quote part of Russia and it's government
support for mr. Trump that should have
been a huge red flag like the correct
response there is I cannot accept
anything of value from a foreign
national in connection with a campaign
especially not of it's part of a foreign
government support for my candidate but
instead Donald Trump jr. replied in part
if it's what you say I love it
especially later in the summer the
meeting that ensued remained secret for
over a year until July of 2017 when the
New York Times published a report about
it Donald Trump jr. initially said the
meeting was about adoption but then a
day later said that the meeting had been
about Hillary Clinton but that the
lawyer had no meaningful information
even if that's true some legal scholars
still think the meeting itself was
illegal depending on your definition of
soliciting and thing of value Kushner
meanwhile failed to mention this and
also several other meetings with Russian
officials on his initial security
clearance application he also apparently
asked the Russian government for a
so-called back-channel that would have
allowed Kushner to communicate directly
with Moscow without US intelligence
listening in much of this is suspicious
Trump jr. Kushner mana Ford and Flynn
have all been caught in lies about the
extent and nature of their contacts with
the Russian government one one none of
it is unambiguous evidence of collusion
or cooperation with foreign nationals
and two none of what is known publicly
involves the President himself except
for him asking Comey to drop the
investigation that said Trump's behavior
toward Russia has it times been strange
as president he had a private meeting
with Putin without a u.s. interpreter
present which is extremely unusual Trump
has also gone to great lengths not to
criticize Putin and he has refused to
publicly acknowledge or condemn the
Putin regimes interference in our
election but none of that is illegal and
connecting the dots can lead to a very
misleading picture when you don't have
many dots what we know is that the
Russian government sought to influence
the u.s. presidential election in trumps
favor that it was one person in Trump's
campaign knew about this and that
several people close to Trump had
interactions with Russian foreign
nationals that they either failed to
disclose or lied about none of the
meetings reported so far involved the
President himself although he did try to
interfere with the ensuing investigation
so that's what we know what we don't
know is almost everything we don't know
what was discussed in the meetings
whether any American accepted anything
of value from a foreign national and we
certainly don't know if any American
participated in collusion with the
Russian government's efforts also we
don't even know for sure what a thing of
value is I think it's important to
follow this story because it has big
implications for the present and future
of our democracy but I also think it's
really important to remember that we are
living in the middle of the story and we
don't know how it's going to end
now if you're looking for information to
confirm your pre-existing biases you'll
find plenty of that on both sides but
the whole truth we just don't know that
yet I hope we will some day Hank I'll
see you on Friday